what color is your clown car walk
and what color polka dots are on your
black car I do not have polka dots in my
car because I'm not a grocery store
that's a grocery store dollar what's
that grocery store Trader knows I know
it's like never mind when you have your
comic upon you have this beard or are
you clean shaven
I actually like to go a little bit more
method so I'll definitely be shaving to
have my entire face painted and you know
this is just for my off season right now
I'm kind of you know deciding where the
next journey of my cloud life is going
to go and do you grow your hair for your
clown look or do you wear a wig of
course not I have to keep it this low so
I can wear multiple wigs I mean the
color the variation the style I would
like to know where you got this one from
I won't tell
that's just rude